[Musica]
io sono un medico che tra i tanti
privilegi
ho avuto il privilegio di stare negli
stati uniti quando hanno descritto il
primo caso di aids e questo per me è
stata una specie di imprinting perché ha
cambiato un po la mia visione della
medicina e soprattutto e e mi ha
accompagnato nella mia vita
professionale ma oggi vi parlerò
fondamentalmente di questo nuovo
concetto giorno della salute globale e
del fatto che esiste esistono nel mondo
delle terribili diseguaglianze in
termini di accesso alla salute
ma partiamo dall'inizio allora questa
questa positiva di far vedere la curva
straordinaria la crescita
dell'aspettativa di vita a partire dal
novecento attenzione queste sono medie
c'è qualcuno che sta sopra e qualcuno
che sta sotto ci sono anche le
differenze tra continenti ma certo è
stata una crescita straordinaria e uno
si dice ma come è successo tutto questo
beh diciamo che il primo motivo vero
quello dei bianche dei primi dell'acqua
pulita l'acqua pulita cambiato la storia
e la vita e la salute di tante persone
quindi l'acqua punita è stato un
determinante essenziale all'inizio però
l'inizio del novecento quando è arrivata
e poi certo i cambiamenti socio
economici perché voi sapete che la
salute non è solo un fatto biomedico no
è legato anche al fatto di dove uno vive
come mangia che lavoro fa e quello che
conta moltissimo quindi sono migliorate
queste condizioni quindi anche
l'aspettativa di vita è cresciuta e poi
certo anche i progressi della medicina
che soprattutto negli ultimi tempi hanno
funzionato soprattutto nel comprimere
verso l'età più avanzata le nostre pato
patologie
qui c'è il buon vecchio jenner hans
giovane jenner che ha scoperto il
vaccino ci abbiamo messo 200 anni a
farlo fuori però insomma comunque
i progressi ci sono stati questi
progressi non sono stati equamente
distribuiti ecco questo è il problema è
che tutte queste cose belle non arrivano
non sono arrivate a miliardi di persone
la salute globale è una branca diciamo
della medicina che si occupa proprio di
lottare contro le diseguaglianze
partendo dal fatto che ci sono venti o
trenta milioni di persone che muoiono
ogni anno per malattie che sono
prevenibili e curabili
quindi muoio non lo dico inutilmente ma
insomma muoiono
purtroppo a causa delle diseguaglianze e
si tratta di milioni miliardi di persone
che vivono in queste situazioni che ce
l'abbiamo sei in totale ma almeno 2
miliardi vivono sotto il livello che
tutti ci aspettiamo allora io prima di
anzi per aiutarvi a spiegare il concetto
di salute globale voglio far vedere che
cosa non è la salute globale perché così
lo capiamo meglio allora questo è un
vecchio articolo cavo scritto nel 2000
figuriamoci in cui il concetto è questo
che la salute non è uguale per tutti e
guardate qualche diseguaglianza questo
per esempio è l'aspettativa di vita in
buona salute perché non è che vogliamo
vivere per sempre
vogliamo vivere in buona salute ecco
vedete quelle aree più chiare
a parte qui l'europa e il quanta gente
ha un'aspettativa di vita in alcuni
paesi intesa raggiunge il 50 per cento
ma con gli etruschi stavano messi così è
e poi guardate questa questa fa
veramente impressione questa è la
mortalità materna per parto in africa
una donna su 20 muore di parto durante
la sua vita qui quando succede è il
disastro giustamente mali è normale si
muore di parto
vedete quanti paesi quelli colorati ed
hanno una mortalità materna
intollerabile poi la vaccinazione i
bambini metà bambini del mondo non sono
vaccinati ma stiamo parando qui della
riferita tetano non stiamo parlando dei
nuovi vaccini e poi certo la tubercolosi
la malaria likes di cui parlerò un
pochettino dopo certo queste qui stanno
sempre lizzano piazzate in quei treni
quei paesi li e guardate questa
interessante questa è la mortalità
prematura per le malattie croniche
c'è il diabete l'ipertensione quelle che
abbiamo qui nei nostri nei nostri lidi
ricchi diciamo la vedete dove muoiono le
zone rosse
l'elettore più scure dove si muore lì
non ce l'avevano di meno
sì ma lì si muore e quello che ho detto
l'altro giorno a questo mio amico di
così mi piglia un piccolo infarto qui
sul palco
probabilmente qualcuno mi raccoglie mi
porta a como dove mi scappano una
coronaria
quando vado in africa a volte me lo
domando e dico certo stupito l'infarto
qui ci rimango e questa e le
diseguaglianze che lì non hanno accesso
ai servizi e alle cure che abbiamo qua e
attenzione non si tratta soltanto del
sud del mondo perché molti dicono beh se
con quei poveri
no guardate questo è il trenino di geppo
possa già proposto è un grande
epidemiologo di torino che ha studiato
la popolazione di torino nel diario e se
un segue il percorso del tram dalle
colline ricche fino alla zona operaia ci
perdono 6 anni di aspettativa di vita e
queste diseguaglianze sono a torino e
non parliamo delle diseguaglianze
all'aspettativa di vita che abbiamo tra
nord e sud italia il 12 ma qual è il
motivo di tutte queste disuguaglianze
beh certo un po bisogno di verità è la
globalizzazione un po selvaggia che c'è
stata perché non c'è dubbio che la
salute è legata alla povertà
i poveri muoiono di più e ammalano di
più per tanti motivi è effettivamente
nella globalizzazione ha portato pure un
po di crescita ma in modo terribilmente
disuguale un per cento della popolazione
mondiale già praticamente tutto in mano
e non c'è dubbio che questa selvaggia
globalizzazione peggiorato anche la
salute delle persone
vedete questi sono i ricchi questi sono
i poveri e fondamentalmente tra l'altro
e di questo si occupa la salute globale
non ci occupiamo saputo dei più
marginalizzati
quindi a partire dai poveri questo è un
homeless ma i carcerati pensare che
cos'è la salute dentro le carceri di
tutti i paesi quindi alcuni e tra
l'altro è una cosa devastante
e poi anche le donne che lavorano anche
diciamo i lavoratori del sesso e come si
dice ma tossicodipendenti che sono i
marginalizzati perché incarcerati e poi
le persone che vivono negli slum se vuoi
sapere che c'è un miliardo e mezzo di
persone che vive negli slam
vi rendete conto di cosa può essere la
condizione di salute là dentro e poi
tutte le persone di persone che si sono
dovute spostare non siamo parlo soltanto
dei migranti ma anche di quelli che
hanno dovuto cambiare paese e quindi
queste sono le persone che stanno peggio
e poi le donne perché le donne vedete
questa di positiva in alcuni paesi del
sud africa il 50 per cento delle donne
giovani sono sieropositive ma certo non
è perché il virus dell'hiv radiosa più
gli piacciono le donne giovani e
semplicemente che queste donne non hanno
gli strumenti culturali e di potere per
proteggersi
adesso abbiamo parlato di aids e invece
parla un attimo perché in realtà è un pò
stata la mia passione della mia vita ci
ho lavorato tanti anni ed è una cosa
positiva e stavolta che voglio dire
perché noi
l'ice lo usiamo un po come modello per
completa combattere le diseguaglianze
allora la storia lunghissima ma avrà
racconto in tre minuti
allora un virus un giorno passo da una
scimmia all'uomo erano gli anni venti
poi si è fatto un gran giro per il mondo
ma rapidamente soprattutto in gran parte
degli anni cinquanta è andato in giro
non c'è paesi che non abbia casi di aids
quante persone sono morte di aids finora
in pochi anni dall 80 quando è stato più
o meno descritto nei paesi occidentali
40 milioni di persone sono morte e altri
40 sono vivono oggi con questa malattia
a un certo punto degli anni 80 e julio
vita ero là
l'ice diventata la prima causa di morte
dei giovani ci ha messo un attimo la
prima causa di mortalità dei giovani e
vedete vi ricordate quanti attori quanti
personaggi famosi morivano di aids
questo è un roccazzo poco prima di
morire poi è successa una cosa
straordinaria
abbiamo collettivamente messo a punto
una terapia e del 96 quindi se abbiamo
messo un po però questa terapia ha fatto
una cosa che a me mette i brividi
io l'ho quando vedo queste positiva
ancora vi vengono i brividi perché come
medico avendo visto tutti i miei
pazienti morire uno dietro l'altro
quando è arrivata questa terapia vedete
la curva rossa questa è la declino della
mortalità per aids diciamo che un certo
punto non si moriva più di aids è stata
una cosa che per un medico è fantastica
ora questa cosa e vedete non sono solo i
numeri è questa e una bambina che stava
lì morendo e dopo sei mesi era e la
stessa bambina è la stessa bambina
allora questa cosa è avvenuta nei paesi
ricchi che si potevano permettere di
pagare questi farmaci costosi e
nell'anno 2000 la situazione invece era
questa che la vedete la curva rossa sono
i morti per aids in africa e quella blu
sono i morti da noi
vedete come bassina perché appunto non
si moriva quasi più e allora io vedere
anzi lo vedete anche l'impatto che aveva
questo sull'aspettativa di vita per
alcuni paesi africani hanno perso 30
anni di aspettativa di vita a causa
dell'aids
io ho avuto anche un altro grande
privilegio che nel 2000 mi hanno eletto
presidente di questa società mondiale
dell'hiv e a un certo punto è venuta
un'idea di come perché non portiamo la
grande conferenza roba da 20 mila
persone in africa
diciamo impossibili ma mi hanno
criticato aspramente non verrà nessuno
sanno poco di starci poi è invece è
stata un successo clamoroso perché sono
venuti in migliaia sono venuti
giornalisti 1300 e poi c'era lui
questo era un uomo di un certo livello e
naturalmente la storia cambia è cambiato
partigiani da durban è cominciato alla
grande battaglia per l'accesso ai media
le medicine alle cure che è continuata
l'anno dopo è stato creato il fondo
globale anche se avete porta i soldi dei
paesi ricchi per ai paesi poveri per
sconfiggerla ma non solo la tubercolosi
e la malaria ma anche l'aids è
effettivamente vedete oggi abbiamo 20
milioni di persone nel mondo che
prendono i farmaci antiretrovirali
ecco questo già vi fa capire perché
light è da considerare un modello per
combattere le diseguaglianze di salute
non solo poi perché ha messo insieme un
sacco di gente diversa
gli scienziati kofi annan ma anche le
chiese e gli economisti con un obiettivo
di sconfiggere una malattia globale la
prima malattia globale della storia
quella che avevamo visto qui e stava
anche giu
e poi ha fatto abbattere il costo del
prezzo dei farmaci questa è stata una
battaglia
diciamo adesso detta così sembra
semplice ma il fatto di riuscire a
portare in ge farmaci generici tutta
l'africa in tutto il sud del mondo è
stata una battaglia pazzesca ma è
successo e quindi questa è un'altra dei
modelli fantastici vedete questo è
l'impatto da quella curva della
mortalità sta andando giù pure in africa
e stanno risalendo le aspettative di
vita vedete come portando i farmaci dal
2000 ecco che sono risalendo
all'aspettativa di vita di quei paesi
quindi l'impatto c'è è bene non è finita
nella storia della ed anche lui ancora
gira
ci vorrà una cura ci vorrà un vaccino
però però è stato fatto tanto e stato
fatto è stato un modello che noi
prendiamo per per parlare di salute
globale ora questo che cos'è questa
bestia qui questo ebola vi faccio vedere
questo solo fatto per spiegare che in un
mondo veramente così globale così
interconnesso con fenomeni migratori di
porta
stai vocale con gli aerei con ma come
possiamo pensare di risolvere i problemi
di salute solo a casa nostra come
possiamo non pensare che per che
occuparsi della salute di tutte le
persone che vivono su questa terra non
sia anche promuovere la salute dei
nostri figli delle nostre generazioni
quindi ecco questo è il concetto della
salute globale oggi abbiamo degli
obiettivi straordinari che sono stati
firmati da tutti i paesi della terra poi
vediamo se ci arriviamo però ci sono 17
grandi obiettivi dalla lotta alla
povertà e alla fame all'ambiente e il
numero tre di questo obiettivo è quello
della salute
questo obiettivo della salute ci dice
che noi dovremmo andare verso la
copertura sanitaria universale cioè il
fatto che tutti gli abitanti della terra
abbiano accesso alle medicine ai servizi
sanitari primari per quel motivo che
dicevo prima perché in un mondo così
globale è impossibile non pensare alla
salute come qualcosa di universale e
globale ora questo è un bellissimo
obiettivo è un po un utopia come però ci
stiamo andando per questo quello che è
stato fatto per l'ice non lo
consideriamo una specie di piccolo
modellino di di sforzo collettivo verso
la salute di tutti
ecco questo è un faro un faro che come
sapete può essere usato da qualsiasi
navigante per raggiungere il porto
ecco questo qui si chiama bene pubblico
questo è un bene pubblico come l'aria
che respiriamo come l'acqua dei fiumi i
parti sono cose che tutti possono usare
chiunque può usare e usandolo non lo
sottrae ad altri questo è il concetto di
bene comune di bene comune e di bene
pubblico e noi pensiamo che la salute e
l'accesso ai farmaci devono essere
considerati dovranno essere considerati
come dei beni pubblici a cui tutti
possono accedere
indipendentemente da dalla
ricchezza del paese in cui si trovano vi
ringrazio
[Applauso]